there are two things that people want to
be able to do to improve their emotional
life you want to be able to choose what
you become emotional about and when you
become emotional that's number one and
the second is you want to be able to
choose how you act when you are
emotional well nature didn't want you to
do either so it didn't give you any
tools so if you're going to learn how to
do this it's going to be hard work and
it isn't going to be the kind of
learning like learning to ride a bicycle
once you learn to ride a bicycle you can
stay off it for ten years and get right
back on and ride what I'm going to tell
you now if you don't do everyday you'll
fall off you got to practice it all the
time it's like being a concert pianist
it doesn't stick unless you practice it
so let's take problem number one having
more choice about what you become
emotional about and that's the only
reason we want that is because sometimes
we become emotional of things that we
don't think merit becoming emotional or
we activate that we don't approve of
afterwards that's the number two problem
the first step is to keep a diary of
when you become emotional now you will
know in advance but you'll surely know
what it's over you just had an emotional
episode write it down in detail do this
for a month then go through it and look
for what are the themes that are causing
your emotions if it isn't apparent to
you get a friend to look at it but it
should be very apparent to you when you
read through this diary and you should
be able to identify three or four
redundant things that are again and
again
getting you to act emotionally now the
ones where you think you responded
emotionally and there was no reason to
be emotional draw a red circle around
them now how many of those have the same
theme now you're equipped you know what
the triggers are now when you're about
to enter a situation think is this
likely to trigger the one of my themes
if so what can I do I calm my mind do a
full body scan do meditation did I not
get much sleep last night so I'm likely
to go off maybe I better postpone this
meeting because it's going to have one
of my hot triggers or am I in pretty
good shape and I'm prepared and I know
what might be coming right down the road
that's step one on problem one step two
is harder
and it is to increase the gap between
impulse and action the way this works
and emotion episodes begin with an
appraisal that something is triggering
your emotion that's based on your
previous life experience that's stored
in what I call your emotional alert
database this diary is trying to find
out what's in that database
but this appraisal mechanism is
continually scanning wherever you are
looking for any of these triggers and
it's incredibly fast and not always
accurate the moment it clicks on
something and impulse arises that
impulse if it gets to the circuitry in
your brain for a particular emotion
it'll set off the emotion in your
expression your voice your posture your
words but there is a takes time for the
impulse to get translated into action
you want to lengthen that time so you
can spot the impulse arising before you
act
this is not easy for some people it's a
lot easier for others because they
normally have a very slow rise time and
others are equal the attack dogs they
have almost instant very little delay
between impulsive action but strangely
enough the only thing that seems to
stretch that out is a contemplative
practice called mindfulness
and it takes a minimum of about 20
minutes a day and at least four days a
week if you want to try it and it will
take about six months to start to have
an effect and then it will only continue
if you continue to do it and you won't
always spot the impulse but sometimes
you'll have the wonderful feeling of
being able to tell I am about to get
angry I think I won't I'll let it go
I'll let that just go right by me
won't happen all the time but sometime
so here are the two techniques one the
trigger diary to find out what's in your
emotion alert database number two
spreading the time gap between impulsive
action now we're ready to move to the
second and somewhat easier step how do I
become aware of the fact that I'm acting
emotionally when I am there are two
things that could ring the bell let me
know that I'm doing it one is pay close
attention to the other person's facial
expressions because they are the
recipient of your emotions you can't see
your own face they see it but you can
see their face and you can tell how
they're reacting and you can say oh my
god there's they're starting to look
very disappointed what am i doing that's
so disappointing them how am i acting
it's one source second source the
changes within your body changes in your
musculature in your respiration in your
sweating in the temperature of the
different parts of your body they are
different we found four different
emotions the problem is we pay no
attention to them the exercise of making
expressions
or being a little Stanislavski actor
recalling past emotional experiences
trying to relive them and focus on what
those sensations are we've got to bring
the sensations that are unique to each
emotion into consciousness so you'll
start to feel it while you're
experiencing it those are the two steps
it's a lot easier for you to learn how
to be more attentive to other people
than to learn how to have any choice
about where you become emotional about
and to learn to have choice and
knowledge or when you're becoming
emotional but it's a good goal and if
you succeed you'll like yourself better
and others will like you